lendemain de la remise du rapport de la
commission sauvé estimant qu'au moins
deux cent seize mille enfants ont été
victimes de violences sexuelles par des
prêtres ou des religieux le président de
la conférence des évêques a mis en avant
le secret de la confession
un secret qui fait débat et c'est loin
d'être la première fois
1961 un aumônier de prison dispose
d'informations pouvant innocenter un
prisonnier il le fait savoir au ministre
de la justice
une démarche personnelle qui étonne à
l'époque jusqu'à son propre évêques qui
est santé des milliers de personnes tous
les jours je confie à moi
je ne vais pas un bonjour subitement
rendre
cette confession ce secret pour dénoncer
pour innocenter pour accuser pour
intervenir que la police que la justice
s'occupe
seule de ce pôle mai
1973 de nouveau le secret de la
confession fait débat un criminel avait
confié avoir tué une jeune fille au curé
de sa paroisse le curé jean claude
brunet ti n'a rien dit scandale il est
placé en garde à vue mais son évêque
venez le défendre à la télévision
steam jeunes c'est de penser aux parents
de la jeune fille
parce que ne peuvent pas comprendre et à
mon tour je les comprends même si
l'attitude de jean claude brunetti me
paraît tout à fait explicables tout
bascule dans les années 2000 avec la
sphère de l'évêque piquant il avait été
mise au courant des actes pédophiles
d'un de ces curés via une enquête
interne et non par la confession il ne
le dénonce pas et l'envoie en maison de
repos les familles des 15 enfants
portent plainte pour non-dénonciation de
viol et d'agression sexuelle sur mineur
une première
l'afer est très médiatisée jusqu'où va
ce secret professionnel pour les prêtres
dès lors qu'il s'agit de crimes commis
sur des mineurs l'église est sommé de
répondre est ce que l'avocat général de
la cour d'appel de rouen n'at-il pas
raison quand il dit que pour ce qui
concerne les mineurs obligation est
faite à tout citoyen quel qu'il soit au
fond de dénoncer le crime je suis pas
sûr que la nécessité d'empêcher de nuire
passe toujours nécessairement par la
dénonciation et par le procès globale
elle peut se faire d'autre façon que je
ferai ce que je peux pour que le prêt tu
arrives à assumer ses actes mais que je
ne n'ai pas à casser un climat de
confiance en 2001 monseigneur piquant et
condamné à trois mois de prison avec
sursis greffer repiquant amène à prendre
conscience d'une chose c'est que
l'église est certes soumises à son droit
elle doit le faire vivre et de faire
respecter mais elle est soumise aussi et
en même temps au droit du pays au droit
des pays dans lesquels elle vit ne pas
dénoncer un acte de violence sexuelle
sur mineur et donc punissable par la loi
mais ce que la justice des hommes est au
dessus de la justice de dieu pour
l'église catholique la réponse n'a pas
l'air encore évidente
[Musique]